it's so funny my uh fiance is kind of
like he's like all-american
i i wouldn't say he's anti-immigrant but
like he makes immigrant jokes
occasionally and i'm like you you know
you're marrying one how does it feel how
does it feel coming in here stealing
your jobs as an immigrant that's what
i'm doing
jordan it's so true well this this
documentary is actually entirely from
the perspective of the migrants
themselves um the reason that i do that
in a lot of cases is because people
perceive my work as anti-immigrant
all the time
um and also because americans tend to
not
look at the border situation or
understand the border situation until it
actually enters america i think looking
at it from the immigrant's perspective
gives you a new a new view on what's
going on
um
at the at the mexican border and then it
also makes it
far more difficult to criticize because
i can see people criticizing and saying
you're only looking from the american
perspective lauren you're only looking
at these people as you know not human
beings they're just like a horde of
invaders or whatever well no even when
you look at these situations from the
migrants perspective this is a messy and
broken situation we're dealing with the
american migration process or lack
thereof right
it doesn't matter whose perspective you
look at it from it it's it's messy and
something needs to change
okay can you um can you give me a
background about exactly what's going on
that's an interesting perspective i
think valuable so what what is what's
the problem and as a canadian i'm like
eh it's america's problem um
but now i'm in america so what exactly
is the problem with immigration between
i guess on the lower border
well i i'd say certainly from the
migrants perspective there is no real
immigration system they hear every day
of friends or family that will apply to
legally go to america and they never get
a call back they never get maybe 15
years waiting in the system or never
anything because they don't have the
financial support they don't have the
job background they don't have someone
they're tied to in the u.s that can
bring them over so the idea of legally
immigrating is
impossible for some of these people and
then they hear time and time again a
friend who's now living in california
new york wherever that
did a month-long trek over the border
and they're living it up and they start
to assume that well that's just the
process you have to go through
especially coming from broken countries
where you know they've got a corrupt
government and if you want to get
anything done you have to pay off a few
cops you have to pay off a few
government officials they look at
america and they're like it's the same
if i want to immigrate there i just have
to go there illegally i have to get a
coyote this is the process to becoming
an american is paying it
is going over elite illegally and that's
very similar to our own governments and
you know what they're not wrong to think
it because america have been letting it
happen for years and years and years and
they're legalizing these people they're
allowing them to live in america after
they immigrate illegally so why are
immigrants supposed to think any
different
that's interesting so it actually is the
process basically yeah basically now it
is you're i you are a thousand
especially if you're one of these people
coming from south america you don't have
a passport anymore you're someone that's
poor living in mexico why
you're not gonna get through legally and
everyone you know that does get over is
typically getting through illegally
why would you do anything else and you
know they even think of it you have to
pay like three thousand five thousand
bucks to some of these coyotes to go
over the border and funny enough a lot
of people could just walk over
themselves but in certain regions
the coyotes uh or
the cartel will actually shoot you at
night if you try to walk over yourself
because they want to make sure that it's
known you have to go through us you
can't just you know make your own way
um so they're like okay yeah when i get
to the border i pay the cartel that's
part of the process and then i get to
become an american
so they actually
they just view that as yeah the system
so did you go down there and do
interviews
yeah so i went all the way down to
guatemala
and
we
i actually illegally crossed into
guatemala but what i've seen oh my gosh
can you say that
okay to say it it costs 20 pesos
i think that's like 99 cents not even so
it costs 20 pesos there and back to go
illegally into guatemala and i'm not
kidding the uh boats that they have that
you take over with these human
traffickers sometimes they are
literally underneath official
immigration checkpoints it's like taking
the piss
you've got the official checkpoint you
can go and do the whole stupid passport
process or you just go under the bridge
and pay 20 pesos and
go to guatemala yeah so we went there we
had a few beers we uh spoke to the
locals that were living across the
sushiate river and then um yeah we
hopped on the boat went back to mexico
and took the
whole trek we followed we followed the
track that they would take straight from
the waterfront all the way to the u.s
border order reynosa
you're insane this is why people attack
you online like who does that
were you stressed out about that at all
um i had armed security you experience
stress lauren
i think i thrive in chaos mikayla okay
it's not good it's not healthy but i do
i try to make it organized chaos enough
that i won't die and what i've learned
after all these
trips as long as you have a local that's
pretty savvy and knows the area and has
connections you'll be pretty okay so i
had i had a really great security team
my one local guy who who was armed you
know always had the glock in the back of
his pants and then
he'd been in shootouts with sicarios and
everything before as well great guy
um and then we had
like a crew that were back at their uh
kind of intel office that would call the
local police and cities that we were
going to and they had great intel like
we were in a city called tierra blanca
and we had three police officers come up
to us and our
um you know intel guys let us know hey
sicarios know you're here they're
watching you so you should get out of
the town before nightfall because
obviously they want to kidnap foreign
crews especially camera crews that they
can get money off of and whatnot so we
got out of that city before nightfall
got to a safe uh different place
veracruz
and as long as you kind of had that
connection or conversation and made sure
you were allowed to do things when i was
in tamalepas we spoke to the cartel and
they let us know areas that we were
allowed to film otherwise they'd shoot
us so we didn't go and film there right
that's fair i mean as long as they're
kind of it's weird um i've spent quite a
bit of time traveling in the last
couple of years and i wasn't aware like
i don't think people in america too a
lot of people like never leave america
are aware of how different cultures can
be but there are cultures that just
operate like that like as long as you
know the rules it's fine it's not like
it's lawless there are rules it's just
the rules are you know from the mafia
and those are the rules so instead of
you know the government right
yeah absolutely and like
okay so people might think this is
unethical but it's not because you don't
get anything done in other countries
that you have to pay off the police you
have to if you go to another country
where you're potentially going to get
killed or there's like lots of crime and
stuff you have to pay off the police for
information just you know or to tell you
where to go or to tell you if they're
gonna like watch you and make sure
you're gonna be safe so there are a lot
of things you can do to be safe and of
course i had lots of opportunities that
um i could have gone and done and
watched that i chose not to because it
was too much of a gamble uh one example
is we actually ran into
i love i love doing this it was so cool
i i was looking on google maps for areas
that i thought might be
major crossing points
in
over the texas border i think it was
across from mcallen texas
and i found this one area where the
trump's wall just stopped i was done i
had a drone so i was also like going
over these areas and looking for areas
that would be breaks in the wall and
trump's wall just stopped and there was
like this texan country club
and i'm like there's no way there's not
human trafficking going on here there's
no way they aren't crossing here because
there's just no border walls so we went
there for like four nights and just
stayed there until because we had been
told by our cartel contact they they
typically go over it around 4am because
that's when switch shifts are for
uh you know american border security
everyone's pretty sluggish at that time
and the first morning we spent there we
ran into human traffickers uh they had
like all these life jackets uh oh i i
was so embarrassing i'm like what do i
do what do i do we're in the middle of
the woods you know there's potentially
armed human traffickers they're walking
towards us and my dora the explorer ass
just walks out from behind the car and
i'm like hola amigos how are you doing
this morning
oh and they they luckily ran off but we
could have followed them maybe would
have gotten some interesting footage but
typically they take two security like
armed guards that pick them off and pick
them up and drop them off luckily we
just ran into the boat men but we
weren't about to find out who they were
being picked up by right so just let
that one be
that seems that seems wise that seems
like a wise decision like do we chase
those people that might end up with you
know guns or no
no good i'm glad you're here now you can
be on my podcast exactly i actually
thought about that there i was like you
know what i've got the michaela peterson
podcast going i can't i can't be doing
this
wow okay so how long did this
documentary take to film
it took a little over two weeks that's
it sounds like such a small time but it
was actually meant to be like a mini
report
actually no it took more than that my on
the ground time was a little over two
weeks and then i did a few interviews
with uh ali bradley and um
dan lyman from border hawk so that was
done afterwards so i'd say the editing
and filming process has been about four
months
wow